Hi, welcome back. Hope you enjoyed video
number six with Chris. I know it was a
little complicated, but don't be too
concerned about it. As I highlighted in
video number five, you don't really, as a
retail trader, have to know the
Black-Scholes formula and implied
volatility from the market.
options prices inside out. As a first
step, what you should be doing is really
just understanding what it means for your
portfolio in terms of the risk in your
portfolio and your opportunities in a
bigger picture way, your opportunities as
a trader. Now we're going to move on to
our second measure of historical
volatility, which we call the average true
range. Now before, when we looked at the
historical volatility of the returns
distributions and odds calculation, the
prices that we took were the open and the
close for the S&P 500. And this can be
repeated for any asset as long as you can
get the data. What we're going to look at
now is a calculation of volatility on a
historical basis using the high and the
low of the day.
And actually you can use this for a week,
a month, a quarter, a year, any time
horizon, but we're going to look at it on
a daily basis. So we're keeping it
consistent with looking at opportunities
on a one day basis as we looked at in the
historical distribution and odds
calculation exercise.
So what we're going to get here now is a
full appreciation and set of volatility
indicators. So we've got two historical
volatility indicators, the historical
distribution and odds calculation, the
historical average true range, and we've
also got the implied volatility, which is
the expected volatility of the asset in
the future.
Once you've got this suite of volatility
measures, indicators, you're going to
understand your opportunities and your
risk a hell of a lot more as a trader. And
you're going to stop taking the
professional trader approach, which is
what we're going to move on to really in
the next section in video eight, when we
move on to how we begin to build a process
to actually get the odds in our favour by
increasing our time horizon.
And looking at that 3% of information,
interpreting the information well in the
correct way and turning it into real hard
dollars. So let's go over to the stage now
where we're going to go through the
average true range. And Chris is also
going to show you how to calculate this in
Excel.
So in Excel, it's a lot easier than what
we've done in Excel, it's a lot easier
than what we've done so far in terms of
distribution and odds and implied
volatility. But we're now using the high
and the low data of the day, rather than
the open and the closed data, or in the
implied using options data.
So let's go through the theory and
practice of the ATR, the average true
range. And then let's go straight to Chris
as well. And he's going to show you on the
computer screen, how to actually calculate
it and how you can use it.
Has anybody heard of this one before? The
average true range. Before we looked at
historical volatility, and we used open
and closed data for the S&P 500.
We're now back to looking at historical
volatility, but we're not looking at open
and closed data. We're looking at the
other data, high and low.
So we're looking for the average true
range of an asset during a day, or over
any time period. You can do it on a week
to week, month to month.
Daily, weekly, monthly, monthly, average
true range. You can pick whatever you
want. What's more important here is the
process.
True range of the low to the high. So the
opportunities in between the open and the
close.
And you can use it for anything. Stocks,
currencies, commodities, bonds.
So how do we actually calculate it?
So let's go through an example of doing
one over five days.
So just last five days, high and low
prices.
Subtract the low price from the high
price, and you get the true range.
Get the average true range, add them all
up, and divide them by the amount of days.
And that tells you, on average, the
difference between the high and the low
for that asset in a day.
Pretty simple.
I think we've got a spreadsheet here as
well.
How do I get into this?
There we go.
There we go. Magic.
Can we see that?
So what I've got here is the high and low
of the S&P 500 going back 50 years.
With the true range and the percentage of
the high low volatility.
So the percentage of the true range.
And how that's trended over the last 50
years.
Okay?
So how many trading days are there in a
year?
Roughly 250.
So we've got 750 days for three years.
1250 for five, two and a half, five
thousand, twelve and a half thousand
trading days over 50 years.
Over 50 years, the volatility, the true
range.
One spot, four, six. High to low.
What's happening to it?
What's happened to it over 50 years?
So what you're looking at here is the
rolling average true range.
It's gone down.
And it's gone down pretty significantly
over the last 10 to 10 years.
You can see a real trend.
Where the difference between the average
difference between the high and the low in
percentage terms for the S&P 500 goes down
by about two thirds, 70%.
Yeah?
So the average now, let's have a look at
the last 60 days.
This was only done last week.
So you're looking at 0.83% between the
high and the low.
Yeah?
10 years ago, it was 1.4%.
Why do we think that is?
What do we think that is?
The what, sorry?
The beast is sleeping.
Yeah, it seems to be sleeping more often.
That's why things have been happening like
this over the last 5 to 10 years.
It's not just in the stock market.
So if you do the same calculation with
currencies, commodities, you'll get the
spreadsheet.
So all you have to do is go and get the
data and dump it into the spreadsheet.
And it'll spit out all the numbers.
So you do it with commodities, currencies,
bonds.
The reasons why it's happening is those
reasons there, really those four reasons.
Firstly, with central bank intervention in
the money markets, bonds and options.
It's not very widely known, and it's a bit
off topic, but one thing that's been
happening in the last 12 months is the Fed
has been selling volatility in the options
market to keep volatility low.
So it's market manipulation.
But more widely known is that the Fed's
been printing money.
Central bank rhetoric, so tail risk comes
out of people's portfolios, volatility
comes down.
But over a bigger structural issue, or
issues, is the number of market
participants in all of these markets.
So the switch from dial-up to broadband in
the Western world, where 15 years ago, if
I wanted to trade the S&P 500, I'd have
had to have probably flown to America,
opened a brokerage account, and flown
back.
Now I can do it from my bedroom in
seconds.
So there's been a huge upsurge in the
amount of market participants all trying
to day trade from their bedroom.
So all of those returns that were
available 10, 15 years ago, they get
petered away.
They get eaten up.
Probably as much or even more
significantly is the onset of algorithmic
trading.
As in, when we go back to the agency model
of the investment banks, the agency orders
going into the market to buy and sell
orders on behalf of hedge funds and
pension funds.
They just go in a machine.
That's how it started.
Then what happened?
Algorithms started to pop up that were
designed to predict what the order flow
was going to do.
So if an order goes into the market to
buy, another algorithm is designed to buy
ahead of it and sell back to it.
It's called scalping.
You scalp half a penny off the robot.
And it's got to such a stage now where
there's even algorithms built to predict
the algorithm that's predicting the order
flow.
So what does that tell you when you look
at those numbers, given the backdrop of
the structural issues in the Western world
stock markets?
It pretty much says, okay, 10 years ago,
you might have had a chance of making
money day trading.
Unfortunately, these days, you literally
have no chance.
Because you're fighting robots that fight
each other.
So you've got to have a portfolio 80% of
the time based on historical volatility
profiles.
Use the historical volatility profile ATR
in different ways.
First of all, use it to calculate your
opportunities over long time horizons.
And if you see in the stock market, if you
see in any market, ATR coming down
significantly over a 10-, 15-, 20-year
period, you know that you're fighting
against the trend if you're going into
that market to try and make short-term
money out of opportunities that are
becoming less and less frequent.
But the second way you use it, that's the
S&P 500.
You can go and do it for any stock, any
commodity, any currency.
As long as you can get the data.
And pretty much, you can get the data for
40,000 assets globally, publicly, by just
Googling around.
You'll get it.
It's all free.
But you can use it for a stock and work
out over different time horizons what your
opportunities are of making certain
amounts of money.
So, I'll do a weekly ATR, monthly ATR, et
cetera, et cetera.
Why is that important?
Because that's going to set the basis or
parameters for your expectations for your
target and your stop loss over that time
period.
So, what do you need to start off as a
professional trader?
You need these three spreadsheets.
And you need to know how to build them and
how to do it yourself.
So, you'll be sent them.
Return distributions and odds calculation.
Historical volatility assessment.
Backwards looking.
Market volatility assessment.
That's implied volatility, like the VIX,
but you can do it for anything.
That's forward looking.
And ATR, historical.
Looking at historical volatility.
Backwards looking information.
Play with those spreadsheets.
Go and get data from different assets.
Dump it in the spreadsheets.
Stretch them, bend them.
Play with them how you like.
If you learn how to use them, you'll be
having some very good conversations with
professional traders.
Well, professional traders that know what
they're doing.
There's a lot out there that don't.
So, as traders we just want to make money
and go where the money is.
If we're being told that there's no money
in these opportunities, we stay away from
it.
And we trade them in a different way.
Or trade something else.
We go hunting.
Get the spear and the shield out and go to
find the big animal that's awake.
Not sleeping in its cave.
That happens 80% of the time.
Cave sleeping is 80% of the time.
If you're unsure of the opportunities,
just run through the exercises.
Once you've learnt how to do it, in the
first month or two, you'll be able to do
it with your eyes closed.
After a couple of months.
And you'll be able to realise what the
opportunities are on a one day, one week,
one month, one quarter, one year time
horizon.
And you'll be able to do it with your eyes
closed.
You'll be able to do it with your eyes
And you'll be able to do it with your eyes
closed.
And say you're talking nonsense.
Or you might have a point here.
Check this out.
You're going to have some very good
conversations with guys who know what
they're doing.
If you follow all of this stuff.
And more importantly, if you just lock
yourself in a room.
Close all the curtains and blinds.
And just go through these things.
You're going to stand a much better chance
of not losing money.
And actually making money.
Because you're not going to allow yourself
to take a position.
When you don't know this information.
It's the first thing you do.
You've got to check all this stuff out
first.
Before you even consider having a
position.
Make sense?
So what's the next generation of retail
traders looking like?
Well, slowly but surely.
This information is seeping or trickling
down to the retail trader.
Eventually they'll figure out that they
can't make money day trading.
Maybe they won't.
We're having this conversation outside
actually.
Do we want them to find out?
Not really.
Because we actually need them for
liquidity on the other side.
So we can get out.
So what have you got to do?
You've got to increase your time horizon
one to three months.
Take a predominantly fundamental approach.
Because over one to three months.
The fundamentals that affect the value of
that asset.
Will be affecting that asset.
Because that's a big enough time horizon
for it to happen.
So fundamentally, top down and bottom up.
So we're going to start from the top down
and then overlay that with bottom up
analysis.
And overlay it with technical analysis and
price action indicators.
And a bunch of important trader processes
for timing entry into your trades.
Into and out of your trades.
Once those positions are real.
And there's real money actually committed
to the positions.
It's all about risk management and
controlling your psychology.
So if we combine all of those factors.
You'll see that we're going to send a hell
of a lot more chance making money.
It's not easy.
No one ever said it is.
But if you go through the processes
multiple times.
You will get process memory.
Muscle memory.
And you'll end up being able to do it with
your eyes closed.
That's where you want to be.
So you can assess something very, very
quickly.
And work out that it's not an opportunity.
And it goes in the bin.
Or work out very, very quickly that
something could be an opportunity.
And do more work.
And figure it out.
How much it's going to pay.
What to do when it goes wrong.
Okay, so Chris is now going to show you on
the computer.
How you calculate the average true range.
The ATR initially for the S&P 500.
But remember you can use this for any
asset.
As long as you can get the data.
For monitoring and calculating your
opportunities.
And later we're going to use the ATR.
In the risk management section.
For how you use it.
In terms of calculating stop losses and
targets.
Within risk management.
So let's go over to Chris.
Chris, take it away.
In this video I'm going to go through an
example of how you can calculate your own
average true range values.
In Excel for a given asset.
So basically average true range is a
historical volatility indicator.
That's computed by taking rolling averages
of high minus low intra period data.
And it basically gives us an indicator of
what trading opportunities there are
within a stock.
Or an asset.
And what trading opportunities there have
been.
And the kind of volatilities we expect in
these assets.
And they'll help us to determine what kind
of trading or portfolio management style
we're taking on using that asset.
So in this example we're going to go
through calculating rolling one day
average true ranges for the S&P 500.
So if we just get started by obtaining the
data.
So we'll go to Yahoo Finance.
That's finance.yahoo.com
And enter S&P into the get quotes box.
And select the S&P 500.
And then go to historical prices on the
left hand side.
And in this example we're going to use
data from the 3rd of January 1962 to the
19th of February 2013.
On a daily frequency basis.
So we just update this price data by
clicking get prices.
And we'll scroll to the bottom of the
webpage and click download to spreadsheet
to obtain the spreadsheet of this data.
And at this point if you want you can save
the spreadsheet to your hard drive and
then open it from there.
Or as we're going to do you can select to
open it straight away and then save it
once the file is open.
So we just open this data.
And as I said the first thing we're going
to do is go to file save as.
Save it as S&P 500 ATR.
Save it on the desktop so it's easy to
find.
And save it as an Excel workbook.
And that's fine.
So we've been presented with the price
data that Yahoo Finance gives us.
The first thing we'll do is adjust the
date column so we can see all the dates.
So we'll just widen that column.
And the next thing we want to do is delete
all the unnecessary columns in computing
our ATR values.
So we only need the open, the high and the
lows.
So we just close column E, F and G.
So we delete column E, F and G.
That's close volume and adjusted close.
To select those quickly I just select on
column E, hold CTRL and click F and G as
well.
And with those columns selected right
click within the selection and go to
delete.
Okay so in column E what we want to do is
calculate our true ranges.
So that will be the high for our period of
trading which is a day, the daily
frequency we have.
Minus the low.
So in column E in cell E1 if we just type
true range.
And in E2 we type equals C2 minus D2 which
is the high minus the low.
And we want to copy that formula down the
whole column in column E.
So to do that quickly we click on the data
to the left hand side in any of the
columns A to D.
Press CTRL and down and then go across to
cell E12871 and press CTRL shift and up.
Which will select all the cells within
column E up to cell E2.
And then press CTRL D to copy down the
formula in E2 to all those cells we have
selected.
Okay.
So the next thing we will do is calculate
the one day rolling average true range.
We will head up the column with 1D.
And that will tell us that will be the
column for our one day rolling average
true range.
So to calculate that in cell F2 type
equals two open brackets sum and then E2
to E3 close the brackets and divide by
two.
So basically this part of the formula just
calculates an average of the last two days
true range.
And then we divide that by the opening
price on the previous day.
So that's B3.
And that will display the average in terms
of the percentage from the opening price
in the previous day.
And we'll do the same thing to copy this
formula down.
So we'll navigate to the bottom of the
spreadsheet.
Select all the cells in column F up to F2.
And then press CTRL D to copy that formula
down.
And with that selection still highlighted,
if we right click within the selection and
go to format cells.
And then change the number to percentage.
So we can display all those in the
percentage terms.
As you can see in the last cell in column
F we've got an error.
And this is because the formula that we've
used to calculate average true range
requires price data from the previous day.
Which we don't have obviously in the last
cell.
So let's go ahead and delete that cell by
selecting it and pressing delete on the
keyboard.
So what will be interesting to find out is
how these one day average true ranges have
changed over time.
So we'll take an average of these one day
rolling average true ranges over different
periods of time.
So we'll just set this up now actually.
So in I3 if we type, or in H3 we'll type
days, in H2 years, and we'll do this over
a period of 5 days, 20 days, 60 days, 250
trading days which will equate to 1 year.
So we'll do this over a period of 5 days,
750 trading days which will equate to 3
years, 1250 trading days which equates to
5 years, 2,500 trading days, 10 years,
5,000 trading days which is 20 years.
And then finally we'll do 12,500 trading
days which equates to 50 years.
So what we'll do from here is calculate
the average of the 1 day ATRs over these
periods of time.
So to do that in cell I4, if we start with
5 days, we type equals average, and we
select, we can either select or just type
F2 to F6, and that will be the previous 5
days average of the previous 5 days ATRs.
And we'll just continue with that method.
So I'm going to F61 here because we're
looking at the average of the last, sorry,
F21 because we're looking at the average
of the last 20 days.
And what I'm going to do to make this
quicker actually is if you copy, so if we
go into cell J4, double click on it, then
we can edit the formula.
If we just copy this, select this text and
copy it, pressing Ctrl C, press Enter, go
to the next cell, K, and press Ctrl V, and
then we'll just edit the formula.
This is quicker than typing it in every
time, so we're copying the formula for
cell J4, we're going to copy it into all
of these cells up to Q4, and instead of
typing it out each time we'll just go into
the formula and edit the last F cell that
we're going to use.
So for 60 days it will be F61, 250 days it
will be cell 251, 750 days 751, and so on.
Okay, so I think just before we summarize
and talk about this data, if we just tidy
this up a bit and we'll highlight these
cells.
We'll highlight from cell H2 to Q2, if we
just put that in a different colour, put
that in a green, and then days, you know,
grey maybe.
And that just tidies up the spreadsheet,
and if we select all the cells from H2 to
Q4, and give them a border by going to the
borders option in the home tab,
and select all borders.
Okay, that's tidied it up a bit.
Okay, so the interpretation of this is
quite simple really.
Basically what we can see is that the one
day rolling average true range has been
trending downwards,
and hence these values, so the five day
average of the one day rolling ATRs is
lower than 20 days, it's lower than 60,
lower than 250,
so that basically is telling us our
volatility has been decreasing.
As we get back to five years, we can see,
or between five and ten, we can see that
the volatilities actually increased from
ten years ago to five years ago.
Now that's quite simply because of the
subprime crisis around five years ago.
That obviously increased volatility levels
a lot.
So that's why this is particularly high,
and that's why we kind of reset a
volatility and slowly work lower and lower
and lower.
And as a general theme, in the last 50
years, we can see volatility decreasing
through our calculated true range values
and one day ATRs.
And this is simply down to basically less
trading opportunities in the short term in
the one day timeframe because markets have
become more efficient.
And so electronic trading systems have
sped up the process of cancelling out
arbitrage opportunities and it's just
decreased volatility as a whole.
So that basically tells us that we need to
expand our timeframe generally if our ATRs
are low, which is a way of looking at
volatility, we have to expand our
timeframe to be able to enter
profit-making opportunities.
So I'll just go back to Anton now, who
will provide you with a quick summary of
what we've discussed here so far.
Hi there, welcome back.
Now, you just watched Chris show you how
to calculate the ATR on a rolling
percentage basis for the S&P 500.
Now, this can be repeated, this exercise,
for any asset in the world as long as you
can get the data.
So now we've got a suite of volatility
indicators where we've got two historical
indicators, the historical distribution
and odds calculation and the average true
range, the rolling ATR.
And we've also got the more sophisticated
one, the implied volatility indicator.
Now, when you take all of these things
together, this gives you now an extremely
professional approach in managing your
expectations in terms of opportunities and
managing your risk because it gives you a
good indicator of what your risk is in the
market and the risk in your portfolio.
Now, the ATR is slightly different,
obviously, because in the other historical
indicator, historical vol indicator, we
looked at taking the data from the open to
the close.
Now we're looking at the high to the low.
So we're not looking at the opportunities
over one day, we were looking at the
opportunities within that day.
And obviously, the volatility of the high
and the low is going to be greater.
But when you look at the rolling ATR in
the example that we looked at, you should
take a message from it.
And the message really with the rolling
ATR in the S&P 500 is that volatility has
been coming down consistently and very
aggressively over the last decade.
And this has been happening for a
multitude of reasons. But the main message
you should really take here is that if ATR
on a rolling basis has been coming down
consistently over the last decade, what
does that mean for short term traders?
It just simply means that the short term
trading opportunities on a consistent
basis have been coming out of the market
over the last decade.
And what we've seen in the last three
years is short term professional traders,
day traders, actually just losing all of
their jobs.
So day trading, day trading shops, day
trading companies have literally been
closing down all over the Western world.
And this is for this is again for a
multitude of reasons.
But one of the main reasons is algorithmic
trading and algorithmic trading is
essentially computer based trading,
quantitative trading,
where algorithms are programmed to go into
the market and scalp and by scalping we
mean going into the market and jumping
ahead of orders in the market to buy and
sell.
And what was that what was that ended up
creating in the market?
Well, it's ended up creating a
self-fulfilling prophecy because now
algorithms are built to predict what other
algorithms are going to do.
So all of the short term opportunities
just keep coming out of the market.
And when you have a look at the rolling
ATR of the S&P 500 there, that's what
you're actually seeing.
You're seeing the short term opportunities
being taken away by computers.
Now, when you become more of a
professional trader and you take the
approach of one to three months, the
computers don't matter.
And day trading doesn't matter because
over a one to three month time horizon,
the opportunities exist.
They still exist and they still exist as
they used to.
And all professional traders know this and
they don't bother fighting the machines or
day trading.
So back to these numbers again in the S&P
500 and major currency pairs.
Well, 80% of the time, so 78% of the time
in the S&P 500 and other major indices
around the world, numbers are very
similar.
And in major currency pairs, 75% of the
time, there's no short term opportunities.
And those short term opportunities have
got less and less over the last decade.
So with the ATR, the ATR really does
demonstrate this.
It demonstrates what has been happening in
the market consistently over the last
decade compared to decades before.
So you should really take that as a
message.
And in summary, what we can really say
about all of these volatility indicators
is that we use them really for two things.
One, it's identifying the opportunities in
the market we're going to trade over any
given time horizon.
To the risk in those markets.
And therefore, the risk of our potential
portfolios or our current portfolios.
Now, once you know these numbers and you
know how to go through these processes.
And remember, as a retail trader, you
should probably be using more the
historical volatility indicators than the
more sophisticated implied volatility
indicator.
When you understand these numbers and you
can go through these processes in muscle
memory, so you can do them very quickly.
What you do is actually you realize
quickly what the opportunities are and the
risk of putting on positions in certain
assets and in asset classes.
And you start taking a more professional
trader approach.
Now, clearly from what we've learned, we
have to understand that the reason why
retail traders lose money consistently
over time is because they try to dictate
to the market what the market should be
doing when in fact the market just does
what it wants to do.
Retail traders have one way of trading and
they never adapt to their style.
They never adapt to what the market is
telling them to adapt to.
And professional traders do the opposite.
So this is what you have to do.
This is what retail traders of the future
have to try and emulate.
And the way to emulate it is to really
deploy a strategy that professional
successful traders and hedge fund managers
actually use.
And they use this with their own money and
they use it with trading other people's
money, investors money.
Now, it's a fairly lengthy process, but
it's actually quite simple.
And we're going to start with this now in
video 8.
In video 8, we're going to start building
out of the process where we're doing
literally the opposite of what retail
traders do.
As in building out of the process for
managing long, short portfolios across all
of the asset classes, equities,
commodities, currencies, rates.
Taking a one to three month time horizon
in all our positions.
Managing that portfolio correctly with due
diligence and risk management.
And becoming consistently profitable
traders.
And your job as a trader is really to make
money from now till the day you retire.
So let's go over to video 8.
I'll see you on the other side.
This is where it gets fun.
Thank you.